la presidenta semara Castro quiere
Mostrar algunos éxitos está teniendo un
gobierno muy complicado ha perdido
aproximadamente 30 puntos porcentuales
en aprobación está a nivel de cuarenta y
cuatro por ciento de aprobación y quiere
Mostrar resultados queremos Mostrar que
ella y su gobierno están en el juego
diplomático que están abriendo
relaciones diplomáticas y que también
están entrando al ring de la geopolítica
china con Estados Unidos no entonces
este es parte de un discurso que lo
viene diciendo el partido libertad y
refundación que es el partido de
gobierno y ahí va a abrir la embajada
china con china popular y que iban a
empezar a hacer también trabajos de
relaciones comerciales y e inversiones
también en infraestructura y en
proyectos de desarrollo este hablemos
ahora de la otra parte qué intereses
tiene China en Honduras
Bueno la verdad es que china Más allá
del de la posición estratégica
geopolítica y la cercanía que pueda
tener con con Estados Unidos Honduras eh
No tiene más allá de no tener otra otro
Aliado en este juego no entre dos
grandes potencias
Honduras lo que le interesa no es ver
cómo puede obtener préstamos apoyo
financiero sin muchas condiciones
especialmente condiciones de temas como
derechos humanos y transparencia no que
es algo que china ya está con esos muy
muy claro que ha jugado ese rol en
América Latina no Honduras le puede
ofrecer café le puede ofrecer mariscos
le puede ofrecer
materias primas como madera pero no le
puede ofrecer lo que china le puede
ofrecer a Honduras que es dinero que le
puede ofrecer también como dije el
posicionamiento geoestratégico que hay
con no tanto puertos en el Pacífico como
en el Atlántico y
así se va a desarrollar esta relación
hablemos ahora de un hecho concreto que
ya ocurrió así en China porque semana
Castro solicitó la admisión de Honduras
al nuevo banco de desarrollo no que está
liderado por los brics y lo hizo en una
reunión con Dilma Rousseff Qué
posibilidades hay de que se concrete
esto y qué implicancias tendría para
Honduras
se va a materializar obviamente
cualquier préstamo que suscriba el
gobierno de Honduras tiene que pasar por
el congreso nacional y el Congreso
Nacional ahora mismo su congreso muy
fraccionado
ha sido muy difícil lograr decretos que
se prueben y ha sido un trabajo muy
complicado que ha tenido también el
oficialismo en poder llevar su agenda se
puede decir refundacional como le llaman
ellos al congreso nacional eh Como le
digo esto es parte de una campaña para
mejorar la imagen del gobierno para
demostrar de que está teniendo
resultados sin embargo Honduras en estos
momentos tiene enorme problemas en
términos de la energía eléctrica tenemos
ahora que está Iniciando el invierno no
se han hecho las obras de mitigación
lo más seguro que van a haber
inundaciones posiblemente también los
riesgos de Los huracanes y estos son los
temas que a la población le afectan y
que este gobierno aún no ha podido
manejarlo ahora esta renovación no esta
nueva era de los vínculos entre China y
Honduras implicó desde su inicio no la
ruptura de las relaciones del país
centroamericano con Taiwán que china
reclama para así recordemos cree usted
que se pueden tensionar aún más los
vínculos de la isla con china con este
nuevo acercamiento entre Honduras y
Beijing
la verdad que es una pena muchos
hondureños
mostraron su vergüenza por la manera
como el gobierno actual rompió
relaciones con Taiwán porque ha sido un
socio por muchas décadas ha dado
bastante apoyo en asistencia técnica
incluso cuando el golpe de estado en
2009 le brindó no seguridad a la hija de
la presidenta entonces hay un sector de
la población que se siente molesto por
la manera como se rompieron las
relaciones No creo de que vaya a ser
Hondura vaya a tener un impacto en las
relaciones o en esto
dilemas que se está dando con los
Estados Unidos China